At the end.
Last time we saw this in temperate quote
from a Herrmann Colby on the young van
off the fancy trifles in it.
His book about the arrangement of atoms
in space are totally devoid of any
factual reality. The reason he
thought, so Colby was the new,
there could be no way of knowing about
the arrangement of atoms in space.
They were just too small,
but he was wrong.
There was plenty of factual reality.
What van Hoff it did was they had
done was to collect information about
isomerism particular about
optically active compounds.
Those that rotated the plane of polarized
light or twisted it. Uh, I've noticed,
uh, in looking at the Wiki, I noticed
some people talk about bending it.
Bending would be like this,
right?
That's not what happens to the plane of
light as it goes. It goes and it twists,
right? It rotates, it doesn't
bend. Bending is refractive index,
you know, like goes into the
surface of water. And then Ben's,
but this is twisting the,
the direction of the,
that the electric vector oscillates.
Okay.
So these optically active compounds
that would do that when in solution,
uh,
were numerous and van Hoff was
able to cite a number of examples.
For example, lactic acid, but you
remember who discovered lactic acid,
Shayla already, you know, close
to a hundred years before this,
Shayla had isolated it from sour milk,
but liebig then found the same
analysis of the acid he got from,
uh, from meat, isolated it
from meat and vistola say news.
At this same time that van
Hoff is working. In fact,
the guy who had one of his
helpers translate the work
of Anton into German for
that publication and was
therefore castigated by Colby.
This Luiseno showed that these things
had the same connectivity by chemical
transformation. These two, uh, acids,
the one from milk and the one
from meat, right? If you look, uh,
40 years later in the
encyclopedia Britannica.
So this is a long time afterwards,
right? Uh, about lactic acid.
It says it's hydroxy propionic acid to
lactic acids are known differing from
each other in the position occupied
by the hydroxyl group in the molecule.
They are known respectively as
Alpha Hydroxy propionic acid.
You remember what Alpha means?
It means on the carbon adjacent
to a carbon eel group. Okay,
so there's Alpha hydroxy propionic acid,
which came from fermentation and it's
called inactive lactic acid. Why would,
why would they call it inactive?
In what sense? Inactive.
And you think what active
versus inactive would mean?
It means whether it's able to rotate
the twist, the plane of polarized light,
whether it's optically active. Okay.
Inactive lactic acid and it gives the,
they give the formula with an o h on
the carbon next to the carbon eel of the
acid group and three hydroxy
propionic acid or hydrochloric acid,
which has the Oah on the terminal
carbon, right? Then they go.
Now these are clearly
constitutional isomers.
It's a different sequence of bonds,
but they go on to say,
although on structural
grounds there should be only
two hydroxy propionic acids.
These two,
as a matter of fact,
for lactic acids are known the third ice
summer in addition to the inactive one
and the one that has the
Oah on the last carbon.
The third is sarco lactic acid.
SARCO means from flesh.
Okay. So that's the one
that leave [inaudible] found
in meat extract. In fact,
Lubick was so, uh, interested in
meat extract that there that he, uh,
that he,
uh,
patented bullion cubes and they were
known for a long time as leavings material
or whatever. I forget exactly. But, uh,
I once looked at a train menu from
the late 19th century, you know,
in the restaurant car, the train, and they
were serving leavings extract. Okay. So,
uh, uh, so there was,
there's the third one is [inaudible] the
sarco lactic acid and may be prepared
by the action of penicillium
Glau Coombe on, uh,
on the solution of
ordinary ammonium lactate.
It is identical with Alpha hydroxy
propionic acid in almost every respect.
Right. Except with regards
to its physical properties.
That's sort of an interesting statement,
isn't it?
That it's identical in every respect
except it's all different. Right.
What,
what was similar about it do you think?
Yeah.
In what way was it identical?
If it had all its boiling point?
Everything was different. Melting point,
crystal form, everything was different.
All the physical properties,
but how could they possibly say it
is identical in almost every respect.
Kevin,
what about as far Mulan?
Obviously it's their isover so
they have the same composition,
but the constitution is the same.
The sequence of bonds, right?
The fourth isomer formed
by the action of Bacillus,
Levo Laconte on cane sugar resembles
sarco lactic acid in every respect except
in its action on polarized light.
So one rotated it to the right,
the other rotated to the left.
And now the of every other respect,
they were identical. So
there were four. Okay. Right.
Left and inactive. Okay. But here,
40 years after, they don't give any
explanation of why that should be. So,
okay. Tartaric acid, we've
seen a lot, right? Shale up,
but say alias coined the name
Isomer to talk about it. Pastor uh,
Vistola Zeno's again showed
the constitution, which
meant nothing to posture.
Why would the constitution mean nothing
to pastor the nature and sequence of
bonds?
Yeah.
Would posture have written at the
time he did this work? Uh, uh,
we don't know anything
about the position of bonds.
I don't think he would've written that.
You know why?
Okay.
Bonds wouldn't be invented
for another 10 years.
There was no such thing as bonds.
When posture it is work
in 1848 bonds came in 1858
right?
So pastor had,
didn't have the tools to think about this.
Okay. So aspartic acid was an example
of something that was optically active.
Angel Alcohol Could Rotate Light
Glucose could rotate light.
Notice that this didn't mean they had
both the one that could rotate one way and
the one that could rotate the other way.
They had something that could rotate
light. In the case of lactic acid,
they had things that would
rotate either way, right?
In the case of tartaric acid after
posture or they had that. Okay.
And also [inaudible] and lactose were
another two that were known but were not
cited by van Hoff. Uh, malic acid.
You know what that comes from?
Where's the root now?
Hm.
It's apples, right? So
it's sour apples. Okay.
And most of the derivatives
of these compounds,
most things you could get by chemical
transformations from these compounds were
optically active.
But not the stuff you got
by dehydrating malic acid.
If you got the double bond.
So you got Malik and
fumaric acid two isomers,
but they didn't, neither of the
rotated light either right or left.
Right.
So that was destroyed in this case.
And also there was another example which
was replacing the Oah by a hydrogen.
So you have ch two ch two in
the middle instead of Cho,
h c h two.
And that particular experiment
van Hoff was involved in,
he was involved in by
suggesting it to his coat,
his fellow student Bremmer,
right,
who did it by treating it with
hydro chaotic acid and phosphorus,
which was a way of removing ohs and
changing them to hydrogen in those days.
We'll see later that that's
called reduction. But at any rate,
there were these two derivatives of malic
acid that we're not optically active,
although most derivatives were.
Okay.
Now van Hoff is,
I said,
was involved at least in
suggesting these experiments. Uh,
and as we said, those two are
inactive in Van Hoff's obituary,
a former student of his band crop
to was by this time of professor at,
at Cornell wrote in his whole life,
he never made what would be called
a very accurate measurement.
And he never cared too.
I remember his saying to be 18 years ago,
how fortunate is there are other people
who will do that sort of work for us,
right?
So it's great to do experiments,
but in some sense it's even greater
if you can talk somebody else who's
confident and to do them for you. Okay.
And that's, that was van Hoff's approach.
Now,
what Van Hoff noticed was that these
compounds that were optically active all
had something in common.
They all had these red,
Adam's in common.
What's special about the carbons that
are red that exist in the ones that are
optically active but don't exist in
the ones that are not optically active?
Why are the, what's special about the
ones that are in Italics and read?
What makes them different? This
is what Vantiff noticed, Chris.
Well they are, but what,
what did van Hoff notice?
Chiral didn't exist then as a name?
Yeah,
they all have bought,
they use their four bonds
to bond to different groups.
No two things are the same.
Down here,
this carbon that was red
here has two hydrogens on it.
Here it has two bonds to another carbon,
right?
But in the other cases, there
are, all these red carbons are,
are unique in bonding to for different
things. This one, for example,
this carbon is bonded
to hydrogen, two O, h,
two n another carbon that goes out on
this chain and another carbon that goes
out on that chain.
And those two chains are different.
This one has a carbonyl
group that has an Oah.
So the difference can be quite remote,
but they're different.
Okay.
So that's what he noticed.
And he called and we now call these chiral
carbons or stereo genic because they
give rise to special stereo
arrangement in space.
So what he said was every carbon compound,
which in solution can rotate the plane
of polarized light contains one or more
asymmetric carbon atoms.
That's what he called these.
That had four different things
and he made models of carbon.
This particular set,
he folded up,
colored the pasted together and gave
to this friend Bremmer who had done the
experiment and they're
in the museum board.
Hava in Leiden now [inaudible] now
look at these things and see if you can
figure out what some of them are.
Here are tetrahedral
whose faces are colored.
So you could make,
if you had four different colors,
that would denote being associated with
four different things and each face
would correspond to a,
okay,
this one has colored vertices. So instead
you could use a tetrahedron. Either way,
you could use the for the faces to denote
a neighbor or you could use the points
to note where a bond is to the neighbor.
And he did it both ways.
What are these here?
What are those models?
Those aren't tetrahedral. Can you see
why he might've made those models?
Kevin,
what do you say?
Nope.
We talked about van Hoff last time.
Last lecture.
Do you remember what he was talking about?
Lucas? Pardon me? Loddon Borg. Benzene.
A triangular prism.
That's what these are.
And you remember this is a
one, two, three, five, four,
six or whatever it is, right? That
are this way. If you color these too,
it's not super imposable on one where you
call this one in this one or this case
that was a B or a B. The other way,
those, he said we're absolutely different.
So those are models he made in with
regard to this argument with uh,
with Lauden board.
Yeah.
Okay. Now here are his models of these
two things you get by removing water.
Pardon me? From, from, from tartaric acid.
So what he has is,
is Tetra heater for the carbons.
And what does he mean when he puts
their edges together like this?
What's the you as part? Pardon me?
What's he using to denote a bond?
There we go.
What's the noting of bond?
A shared Vertex,
right? So here's a single
bond, right? What's this?
A double bond.
That's like what Lewis did later.
Remember when he brought cubes together
to share an edge or a little bit like
that at least.
But now when you do that,
when you share an edge and and have
the other two things on each carbon,
they're different. This one
read and not read, right?
You could put them together this way,
but you could also put
them together this way
and you can't get from one to the other
without pulling them apart and putting
them back together again.
Right?
So that would explain why there
are two different isomers Malai,
ACC acid and fumaric acid,
right?
That you get when you start with tartaric
acid and pull off the water or start
with malic acid. I was saying
tartaric you start with malic acid,
pull off water and you
get either this or this.
Okay? So he could explain that
with his tetrahedral models.
The red denotes a red vertex.
Okay.
Or if you have a single bond,
you could count isomers.
Now what he says here is you don't get
all that many isomers because it can
freely rotate about the
bond between the two.
So the carbon atom is in the center of
a tetrahedron and it's substituents are
on the virtus vertices, right? So
the top carbon has three things,
r one r two r three and what he shows
here as you can rotate that freely,
you don't count all these as separate
isomers who would have thought you did
count them as separate isomers.
You may not remember the
name. Where was he? What?
The guy from Palermo, right?
Paterno was his name, right?
He tried to explain the existence of
isomers by say, but Vance Hoff says, no,
that's not true. You can freely
rotate. So you can't count that.
But you could have,
if you look down on r one r two r
three you could look down and see them
clockwise from one to two to three or
you could see the counter clockwise from
one to two to three and you can't go
back and forth between those by rotating
cause they're in a certain order.
So you do get a isomers.
So he made this diagram to show that
free rotation about the central bond
results,
results in rapid inder conversion and
thus inseparability and the irrelevance of
the isomers that Paterno talked about.
And they can be arranged
clockwise or counterclockwise,
which is not affected by the
rotation about the central bond. Uh,
and you can then count how many isomers
there are depending on whether r one r
two r three are the
same as a four or five,
six or are different from
four or five. Six. Okay.
But maybe the most spectacular thing
he showed was that if you put three
tetrahedral together like that,
you get these forms,
which what's the relationship
between these two?
Can you super impose them and
have them be exactly the same?
Okay.
Is there any relationship between them?
Obviously used to just slid them together
are one would be on top of are one and
two on two, but four and
three. But, uh, but uh,
for this is a four here,
it looks like a one,
four and three would not be on top of
one another when you slide them together
and there's no way of twisting
it, so it'll be right. Right.
But there's a special
relationship between those.
They're not completely unrelated.
What symmetry relates to them?
Do you see Zach? Right. Yeah,
there are mirror images. Like
right handed and left handed. Okay.
So he predicted that if you had two
double bonds in a row with a common carbon
in the middle,
then you could get right and left handed
where you can't get it with just the
double bond as in the
bellyache and fumaric acid.
Those aren't chiral as we now say.
But this wasn't shown until 1935 that was
probably the longest that that there's
been a correct theory proposed until
the time that it was confirmed.
At least I don't know of
anything longer than that.
61 years after he predicted it before it
was demonstrated to be demonstrated to
be true. And it was proved. You
see in the labs of a Kohler,
the same guy we talked about last time,
uh,
and here's the molecule he used down in
the bottom left and we can enlarge it
here.
So there it is.
Now that molecule,
as you look at it would be super
imposable on its mirror image.
It looks planer right now.
Let's think about that.
That bonds at that carbon
should be tetrahedral.
So one bond should be coming in and out.
Or one pair of bonds and the other
box parabon should lie in the plane,
but if that's true,
then the one on the right would have
it's four bonds Co Planer, right?
All in the plane of the paper.
So there's something wrong here
and you can see what's wrong.
If you think about the P orbitals
that go into making a double bond,
right?
What's wrong with that arrangement?
Why don't the P orbitals like it? There
are thug and all. They don't overlap,
right?
What you need to do is to twist it like
that so that the groups see 10 h seven
and c six h five come in
and out of the plane, right?
And that's what then makes it not super
imposable on its mirror image. Okay?
Now if you wanted to convert
one mirror image to the other,
notice if you use the plane,
is that something parallel
to the screen as a mirror?
What comes out in front of the
mirror would be the same on the left,
but on the right,
see 10 h seven would be back in and
c six h five would be coming out,
right?
So if you want to inter convert these,
you have to put 10 where
six is and six where 10 is,
you have to rotate around the bond.
But to do that you have to break
the bond because it's a double bond.
You'd have to go back to where the P
orbitals don't overlap and you lose the
double bond and then you can keep rotating
and get the other mirror image isomer.
Right? But you have to break a bond
to do that. So that's very tough.
Okay. Now we were counting isomers
in homework for today and uh,
this, this, uh, slide goes through and
council, I'm just going to begin it, uh,
and then hustle through the end rather
than go through it in great detail
because you've already worked on it. But
this can be thought of as an answer key.
Okay.
So we want to count how many different
Mano substituent positions there are in
that compound. There's one. Okay.
There's obviously a different one too.
Now how about three?
Is that different if you have
just a mano substitution?
Is the blue different from their Ed know?
Obviously,
because this thing has rotational
symmetry, you could rotate it.
Put the red on top of the blue. So the
blues, not a new one. Forget blue. Okay.
Now how about that blue one?
Is that a new one?
No, because the one in the left front, uh,
would go on that same rotation.
Go to the right rear.
So that one doesn't count. How about
that one? Is that different or the same?
Can you rotate it? So the one in the
front left becomes the one in the front,
right? No. So now we have a question.
Is that something real about the models
or is that just like the sausages that
calculate years that it
suggests a difference when
there's not a real difference.
Okay, so we'll put a question
mark on that one. Okay.
So there are two isomers if we don't
count the two on the bottom and there's an
additional isomer if we do count it.
Okay.
So they're either two isomers or
conceivably three isomers of that one.
Okay.
And notice that this one,
the third one in has exactly the same
arrangement among the hydrogens is the
first one.
So the numbers would be the same to an
additional one if you count those extras.
Now here you have obviously
three different positions
you could have for mono,
top, middle bottom, but also, uh,
the ones on the right are not super
imposable on the ones on the left,
if this is three dimensional.
So you could have another three
if they count and so on. Well,
I'll not go through these,
uh,
notice it except to note in this one
that there's obviously top here and these
three. Now the question is, are
those three different or not?
And were used following van off here and
saying it rotates rapidly around here.
So on time average, you won't be able
to put those in separate bottles, right?
They're going to inter convert to
rapidly to count. So there'll be three,
but the two on the top
right are not really,
they are not super imposable
by rotation in the model.
Okay? So the question is whether you
have that additional one in Brisbane,
there's only one. And then if you go die
substituted, if we start on the left,
if you, if you, if you, uh,
start with one on the top here,
you can have the second
one here or here or here,
that's clearly three,
but there might,
this one is not super imposable of
that is if you have this one already,
this one in this one as sites for the
secondary, not super imposable, right?
So maybe we need another one there
and another one over here as well.
So there might be an additional two.
And again,
this is the same as that one and you can
go through this and presumably you have
done. But anyhow, these
are the answers I got.
And if you found something different,
let me know.
Maybe you saw something I didn't see.
Okay, so that's interesting. Now,
mirror images. Here's me with
a mirror image. Right now,
this is a question.
Uh,
why does the mirror
exchange right and left,
but it doesn't exchange top and bottom?
How does the Mirror knows
which way gravity points?
Or how about if I lay on my slide on
my side, when I looked in the mirror,
would it still exchange left and
right and not top and bottom?
I'm talking about plane mirrors,
not fun house mirrors.
That's an interesting problem,
right?
But notice it doesn't change either
cause top is on top and write is on,
right? It didn't change. Right
and left it left. Right on.
Right.
What did it change?
Why does the mirror image look
different from the real image?
If it doesn't change right and left
and it doesn't change top and bottom,
it changes front to back or in and out.
Right?
Because my original self, you see the
back of my head and then the mirror image,
you see the front of me.
So what a mirror changes is in and out.
Not right and left.
Okay.
But our intuition interprets that as
rotation because if I look like this and I
go like this,
right?
You expect it to change the right hand
because you're accustomed to people
rotating.
You're not expected me to go like
that and turn it inside out. Right.
Okay. So people don't invert. So our,
our mind makes us think that the person
we see in the mirror has turned 180
degrees so that the right
should be on the left. Okay.
And then of course you,
this was,
this is not a new observation
through the looking glass, you know,
Lewis Carroll and Alice
going through and here's,
here are successive pictures in that book.
There she is looking into the glass and
we turn the page and here she is coming
out on the other side.
Now notice something about this.
That's her right arm.
All right?
Okay.
And in the previous picture
it was also her right arm.
That's not the way the
mirror image should look.
It should have changed the way it
looks when you go from back to front.
Okay. Now, Lewis Carroll was a smart guy.
He taught mathematics at
Oxford. Right? Of course,
he didn't draw the picture.
The picture was drawn by John Tenniel
and it turned out that John Tenniel was
blind in one eye.
A fact I only discovered
yesterday on Wikipedia.
So is that the reason that he's unable
to perceive depth and draws the wrong
thing?
No,
it's much more subtle than that.
Notice that the name of the book
is through the looking glass.
She moved through the looking glass
and her right arm stayed right,
but if she had been reflected
in the looking glass,
if the title had been chosen to be in
the looking glass rather than through the
looking glass,
then when you looked at the mirror image,
it would have been the left arm.
That's sort of cute.
So Carol is more subtle than
you might give him credit for,
or John Tannehill or both.
Okay.
Or look even further in the book.
This was notice 1872 what was going
on in chemistry in 1872 these visceral
Zeno's news was studying
these isomers of lactic acid.
The Shayla and the levy can showing
that they had the same constitution,
but we're different.
Okay,
so look what happens here when
she's talking to her kitty.
Now if you'll only attend
kitty and not talk so much,
I'll tell you all my ideas
about looking glass house.
Well then the books or something like our
books, only the words go the wrong way.
I know that because I've held up one
of our books to the glass and then they
hold up the one in the other room.
How would you like to live in
a looking glass house? Kitty?
I wonder if they give you milk.
They're
perhaps looking glass
milk isn't good to drink
because in the college,
uh,
Carol knew Vernon Harcort who was a
chemist who was involved in this work with
this Luiseno who's so almost certainly
they'd had conversations about lactic
acid, the mirror image form, right? So
there's a lot of stuff in the Alice.
So where's he referring
maybe to sarco lactic acid,
the one that comes from meat
instead of from sour milk. Anyhow,
Kyra [inaudible] comes from the
Greek word hair, which means hand.
It's handedness.
So there's a right hand.
Now let's talk about that. And Lord
Kelvin coined the word. He said,
I call any geometric figure or group
of points chiral and say it has Kyra
Allity. If its image in a
plain mirror, ideally realized,
so don't take into
account, you know, uh, uh,
moles or a fingernail that hasn't
been trimmed or something like that.
Ideally realized cannot be brought to
coincide with itself by rotation and so
on. Okay, so let's consider
Xyz coordinate system.
So they're coordinating their points for
every every cert point on the surface
of the hand.
And I could make an image
of it by changing some of
the signs of some of these
things.
For example,
I could leave all the Z and
y coordinates identical,
but change the sign of x,
which would move things from being
on that side to being on this side.
You got the idea?
Okay,
so I'm gonna make a new hand that looks
like the original one except every x
coordinate has changed at sign change
all the x coordinates and we get that.
Everyone see it ideally realize the
shadows a little different and so on.
But ideally realize those are the, those
are the ones that have done that, right?
Changed one sign.
Now is one hand right?
On the other hand left or are they both?
Right.
Okay.
So what,
what kind of relationship would
you say there is between these?
Are they super imposable or are they
non superimposable mirror images.
Okay.
Can you rotate and put one on top?
Exactly the coincide or the other doe.
Because there are right
hand on the left hand.
But that operation chorus changing the
sine of x corresponds to reflecting in a
mirror,
which is y z in the Y Z plane.
Everybody got it leaves y and z.
That's like leaving top, top and right.
Right. But changing in and out
this way. Okay, so that's a mirror.
Now what would happen if we changed all
the y coordinates and you see but left x
and z the same.
Then you'd get this.
Okay.
And what does that correspond to?
Is that a rotation or a mirror
if your left
hand.
So they both left hands.
This one,
right? And this is a right hand
and suddenly not a left hand.
And if I rotated that would look like
that. Right? Is that the way it looks now?
It looks like that. Right? So what
was the operation that did that?
Mathematically it's changing the sign,
but how would you describe it in
terms of mirrors and things like that?
It's a horizontal mirror that
leaves right left in out the same.
But changes up down top, bottom. Okay,
so that's reflection and an x, z beer.
Now suppose we change the
sign of all the z coordinates.
Can you guess what that's going to do?
Not Rotation.
Change the sign of z.
So that's going to give that one
change in and out. But leave right,
left and back for a DA.
Back Change.
Right left and top box. Pardon
me? Leave right, left. Leave top.
Bottom. But changing out. That
gives the one in front. This one,
right? Okay, so that's the
reflection in the x, y mirror.
Now there's some there. We've
occupied now four of the [inaudible],
but we can occupy the other four as well.
For example,
we can change the sign of all x and Y,
but leaves z the same.
Can you see what that's got to do?
Change acts.
Change y but z the same.
Okay.
There. And what operation
was that? Was that a mirror
rotation? About what? About z?
The one that didn't change.
Right? How about if we,
that's rotation around the Z axis.
How about if we change all the and zs,
but leave. Why the same?
What's that? Got To do.
That's easy once you know the previous one
that's going to rotate about the y axis.
Right?
And how about if we change the sign
of y and Z and leave x the same.
Sophie,
do you see?
So we're going to change the sign of
why and change the sign of Zhi from the
original one back here.
We're going to change why?
Up and down and we're
going to change, uh, z.
Did I say? Yeah, Z in
and out from this one.
Does that one.
All right.
That changes in and out and
it changes up and down. Right?
And what it is is rotation
around the x axis.
Now there's one up [inaudible]
that hasn't been occupied yet.
The the one that's out front,
top left.
Can you see how you get there?
What haven't we done yet?
If you change all three x and y and Z,
then you come up there and
get the eighth one. Okay.
Now what operation is that?
It's in version through
the center of symmetry.
It's what I tried to do bikes like that,
but I couldn't change myself inside out.
Right?
So there's the center of symmetry there
and every point on the back has has one
the same distance and along the same
vector to the front right there or to the
base of my thumb. Okay, so here there are,
we looked at three mirrors,
three rotations and an inversion.
Some of them changed right to
left and some of them didn't.
Some of them were super imposable.
Right?
Can you see in terms of changing signs,
what determines whether it's going to
be the same high end or the other hand?
Angela reflection.
The reflection changes hands.
So if you change x or y or Z,
any other way to change hands
if you change everything x and y and z.
So if you change an odd number,
then you change the hand.
Okay.
So Kyra [inaudible] handedness is non
super imposable mirror images and it
involves an odd number of
changes of coordinates.
Now notice the right hand
has only one mirror image,
the right and the left are
mirror images of one another.
I can put the mirror image here or I can
put it here or I can put it here, right?
So which mirror I use determines
where the new hand is going to be.
But it's always the same
mirror image. Okay. Uh,
just generates it in different
locations in orientations.
Now this is a special property
handedness, right? Or is it,
is it an everyday property?
Right. We've looked at molecules.
Van Hoff was able to come
up with a what about, uh,
less than a dozen examples from all the
molecules that have been known up to
that time.
So what do you think,
do you think most molecules are chiral
or do you think most organic molecules
are not? Chiral? Uh, well,
we had an exciting night last night and
learned about the democratic process.
So the way to settle such a
question is to vote. Okay,
so how many, we're going to vote
on how specialists Chi rally first.
Very special, right? Only
unusual molecules will have it.
Or on the other hand,
you're like these carbons that have
four different things or alternative.
It's very general. And what's
unusual is ones that are a chiral,
not like hands.
So here we go.
How many people think that
[inaudible] is pretty special?
Okay.
Be a little like Indiana.
How many people think corralled
is not so special? Oh,
not very many. That's what I
anticipated. It's pretty special.
The class voted overwhelmingly.
There should be more keyer.
A keyer all didn't chiral molecules and
the voice of the people is the voice of
God.
All right,
so let's look at words. You
can use words. Alice said,
hold up or book to a mirror.
Okay, so here's a message.
Let's decode at noon,
but keep it mom. Okay,
now let's make the uh,
change the sine of x.
So we get the mirror image of
this. Okay. It looks like nonsense.
Is there anything special
mum?
Mum is its own mirror image.
Thus it's not handed.
It's a chiral.
Right?
But it's the only word that has that.
When you change the sign of x,
it stays the same. It's pretty special
to be a chiral. There'll be mom at least.
Okay, here. Now, any other
words look interesting?
No one looks sort of interesting.
Is it super imposable on its mirror image?
No. [inaudible] so it's chiral
handed. Like most words.
You can have a right or a left handed
noon. It does have symmetry though.
Watch what happens if we instead
of do use it in a mirror,
rotate the message on the right.
So change both x and y.
And now you notice what
noon is the same.
So it has symmetry, it has
rotational symmetry, right?
But not mirror. Okay. In two dimensions.
So it has rotational sim do that,
but that doesn't keep it from being
chiral like a propeller is Kyrell.
It has rotational symmetry. Okay. Now
let's mirror by changing the sign of why
anything special here.
What do you do that
decode is the same.
Okay,
so decode is a measle word,
right?
It's a chiral.
Uh,
but it's harder to recognize because
we're not accustomed to dealing with
mirrors that are horizontal.
We're much more familiar with
mirrors that are vertical.
So it's much easier to see it
in mom than to see it in d code.
So you can amaze your roommates with that.
Okay.
So how specialists carnality
in the case of words,
it's not at all special, right?
What's special is to be a chiral,
to have some kind of special symmetry.
Almost all words are Chiral,
but there are certain a chiral or
Misa words such as mom and decode,
but they're very rare. Okay?
That's the same with molecules.
Almost all molecules are chiral.
But if you work with very,
very simple ones as you do
when you begin to do chemistry,
then a lot of them are a chiral.
But it's a very atypical example.
Essentially every
molecule in you is chiral.
All your amino acids, all the sugars,
everything. Almost everything.
Fatty acids aren't Chiral, but when
there are parts of fats, they are Kyrell.
Okay,
but why did we deal with
very simple molecules?
We often encounter a chiral are Misa ones.
Now we're going to go beyond
constitution into Stereo Chemistry.
So we've talked about composition,
we've talked about constitution,
the nature and sequence of bonds,
and now we're going to go
into configuration and con
formation. The other two CS,
these last three C's all
have to do with isomers,
but there's a difference in that.
The last two have to do
with arrangement in space.
What the traditional chemists warn the
young folks not to think about at in the
third quarter.
The of and early fourth quarter of the
19th century and what the encyclopedia
Britannica still didn't
know about by 1911. Okay.
But what's the difference between
configuration and confirmation?
The distinction is based on
the model we make, right?
And uh,
because configurational
isomers relate to one another.
By breaking a bond,
you have to break a bond to go from one
to the other and reassemble the pieces,
right? But when you're
talking about Khan formation,
you can do it by rotating
from one to the other.
So Paterno was talking about
isomers that related by rotation.
His particular ones rotate so easily
that it's very hard to see different
isomers in his case.
Right?
Although you can get information
about that kind of thing, right.
But the ones that require breaking
a bond to go from one to the other,
those are much more easier to deal with.
Right.
And so we have different names for them,
but it relates only to the,
to the model.
We use that talking about
bonds that whether you break
them or not and you won't
be surprised to hear that there's some
bonds that are so easy to break that it's
easier to convert those configurational
isomers than it is to convert certain
conformational isomers where formerly all
you have to do is rotate about a bond,
but in the process other things run into
one another and make it very difficult.
So it's configuration and
confirmation relates to the models.
We draw the molecules not to something
the molecule itself fundamentally knows
about. So that one's hard to get back
and forth and that one's easy typically,
but it doesn't have to be that way.
Okay,
so all isomers represent
local energy minimum.
That is if you are a
low enough temperature,
the molecule could sit in that
structure and just vibrate,
have had zero point amplitude of vibration
around that particular structure.
But then you can get from one to another.
You don't take every possible structure
as Paterno tried to do and say that all
of these structures are isomers because
then there'd be an infinite number and
they wouldn't last any time
cause they're always vibrating.
But you can vibrate within a little well
here or a little well here or a little
well here.
And those are different isomers,
not just different phases of vibration.
Now the words of stereochemistry
often involve relationships.
For example, two molecules that
have exactly the same constitution,
nature and sequence of bonds
can be identical. Okay?
They're super imposable and if
you wanted the name for that,
you would call them home omers but no
one needs to use that because it's always
the same thing.
So that word doesn't really exist.
But if they're just completely different,
then you call them Daya Stereo Merz,
which has the same root as diameter.
Things that are as far apart as you can
get right there just playing different.
Those are Daya, Steria, Mers, but
they have the same constitution,
the same nature and sequence of bonds,
but they're just completely different
in their arrangement in space.
Or there can be a very special relation
in space. You know what that is?
They could be mirror images,
which are not the same thing,
but they're going to be very
similar in many respects, right?
So that one has a special name.
Dietary fiber just means different.
But Ian Anti Omer Means Mirror image,
right?
Okay. So these are relationships
between two molecules.
You say this molecule is the
Ian Anti Omer of this molecule.
Okay?
Now
we need to talk about things like this.
As Lovaza ta ta told us we
need to think about the facts,
the ideas and the words.
And when we come to words,
now we need to convey such
complicated ideas. We need pictures,
not just written letters.
Okay?
So we need pictures for our notation
that will show this third dimension.
Now there are a number of tricks you
can use to do that. Uh, what's the,
can you see what's being used here
in this particular picture of it,
which is an old fashioned picture.
When a laptop computers were new
and you had very simple programs.
Yeah,
I can't hear
relative size is one. Right. The, the
hydrogens that are far back our small.
Anything else?
Any other
clues that show the three dimensions?
Yeah.
Can't hear very well.
No.
The lines for the bonds,
they're thinner in the back and notice
that some of them are wedges showing that
they're coming in and out.
Anything else?
Corey,
how do you know whether they're
in the front of the back?
Like this one?
How do you know it's in front of this one?
Because it hides it
right?
That's a way you can do.
You can tell there's another one which
is if you look at this one with the left
eye and that one with the right eye,
your brain is able to put it
together in three dimensions,
so it'll be hard for you to do.
I don't expect you to do you usually
use glasses to do that. Okay.
But you can see that there are different.
Look at this hydrogen here.
There you see the bond and there it's
being a little bit obscured, right?
So there are different images
that your right and left IC.
That's why a 10 year old might have
had trouble with the third dimension.
Okay? Uh, now, uh,
there's another way which is motion.
So here's a complicated picture, right?
It's hard to tell what's in and out,
but I grab it and do this.
Then you can perceive what's
in and what's out, right?
So if you have a picture that moves,
which didn't use to be possible of course,
until you had computers that could do
this kind of thing. So that's another way,
uh, uh, uh, motion.
Uh, there's that same
molecule. There are other ways,
like what's new in this one?
Shadows, right? Or here,
more obscuring and shadowing of
the balls or here, even better,
right? Depending on what you want
to show. So there are lots of,
of conventions or tricks that are used to,
to convey the third dimension.
Uh,
okay.
And next time we'll go on to to simple
notation that you can write on an exam,
like showing tetrahedral carbons.
Okay.